good morning Millennials excuse us we're
just a little tardy for the party
because we're so busy launching our
billion-dollar merch brand
we're so excited as you guys know or
maybe maybe we're curious about
obviously merch is going live today and
it's going live on this show as we end
so it is merch day we told you February
14th so many new styles new collections
bringing back some favorites the pop
sockets the hat that I'm wearing in a
few different colors some new pop
sockets some new hat of new hats we
posted a picture from three years ago of
us wearing scenes hats that we made for
ourselves like when we were just excited
to be scenes and then everyone assumed
it was new merch so we just made it so
we really - yeah so you can get a Steans
hat we got new pop sockets new t-shirts
very cool you know accessories we got
bumper stickers we got notebooks so just
make sure at the end of the show you had
to shop morning toast calm it is
unlimited stock so nothing can sell out
for 24 hours so you'll only be able to
get this stuff for 24 hours Sorority
sweatshirts are back bye-bye demand do
you know the sorority's sweatshirt is
like the coolest thing ever so many
people were like I already own one but
now I want to get an oversized one to
wear with thigh high boots and be ariana
grande and you know what ariana grande
did I don't know if she knows about the
toes but she would be a toaster if she
had totally and she does not have the
time and what I love about the
sweatshirts for a million reasons this
is up there $40 and every Specter merch
wise is like $60 plus so I'm really
proud of the fact that we have a quality
sweater for $40 yeah we tried to make it
you know as economical for you toasters
as possible because we love you and we
just want to get back to you and we love
you so much that's why the merch is
dropping on Valentine's Day and you know
what like you hopefully you will get
gifts aplenty but you should treat
yourself and buy something for yourself
and I think that's the gift of the toast
the galentine's Day Valentine's Day you
know that's a word that I try not to
like come out of my mouth you know what
that's a word invented by losers I'm
sorry like it's not if you don't have a
Valentine that's totally fine but like
to make yourself feel like you have to
like hang out with your girlfriends like
it's perfectly fine to be by yourself -
I feel like galentine's Day was invented
by honestly like corporate sponsors who
are like it is a national day February
10 stay in your planner probably says no
and I feel like it was made by Bank of
America like trying to get in on a trend
like yeah like shove our sale for
galentine's like saying it hurt it feels
like a kick in this stuff
is the lamest thing ever it does not
look cool on the stream what do I look
like wienie sure - no you look cool you
look honestly like a counselor I know
but I didn't like I spent a good amount
of time on my hair like is it being
ruined
no and it's bringing out the scarf and
remember last year on Valentine's Day I
were all pink and you were all black and
it was like we were the two types of
girls on Valentine's well I literally
forgot and I wore all black today but
then I just threw this scarf on because
it was my Valentines Day gift that I
literally requested from Ben and I loved
it so much and now it matches my hat and
it's I guess yes it's very a Valentine's
and it's merch a so people need a
constant reminder that after the show's
over you don't have to go back to the
watercooler with Sally you can go
shopping online your shop for marriage
marriage French marriage merch
I love me some merge merge merge merge
first the morning toast burns burns
burns burns mercs makes a badass merge
merge merge merge merge a meal of our
each when we get it when you guys get it
like we order it whatever allows
everyone else so what I like I get just
as excited and then I can literally wear
it every day you know what and usually
like I get it for free I think I'm gonna
place in order this no I'm gonna place
in order because I feel weird I mean not
like I can be a casa on my own word sure
but I feel weird having into our own I
need at least seven don't worry be
toasty shirts I need one for every day
of the week because I'm always worried
when I shouldn't be and I shouldn't be
being monkey
I should be being toasty I couldn't
agree more so I'll be doing the same and
you know it's sometimes it's don't worry
be toasty five days in a row I mean I
don't even have a car but I'm getting
bumper stickers for my apartment I'm
getting member stickers to put on my ass
cheeks so when I walk down the street
people will honk at me I I'm totally
here for it no if I had a car I would I
would have bumper stickers for sure but
I wouldn't be like you know a million
bumper stickers like no set coexist so
like I wouldn't like for somebody it's a
great message I stand behind the message
completely and how every every letter is
a different religious or like yeah and
it's beautiful the message don't get me
wrong but there's something about it
that is so [ __ ] ugly and it's like it
only is on the back of terribly old a
station wagon
yes it's like if you have a coexist
sticker on your butt on your on your
bumper like your car doesn't work you
know there's something wrong inside with
your car that's being affected on the
outside by the sticker
we should make for
next my shop like revamped cuz I love
that idea we had palm trees and my so
toasty yeah but like same message ya
know the don't get me wrong I love the
message I'm here for the message I just
think aesthetically it could use an
update yeah and you know it now that I'm
thinking about the message like coexist
why should we just exist together
Naoko live yes yes oh my god this is
such a good idea okay maybe we can add
it to this or anyways this is such an
exciting show there's so much to be done
you know obviously the Fast Five
obviously we have to talk about
ourselves obviously we have shows to
recap I watched siesta key but also we
got rushed a little bit yesterday cuz we
want to be sure Melissa had enough time
today the dead All Stars
it's my last show as a single woman oh
my god yeah we borrow it's so apt that
it's Valentine's Day I really am a
galantine today did you intentionally
get married this week because it's
Valentine's Day um it was part of it was
part of the thought I just think like a
Valentine's Day wedding is so sweet
thank you but you know who gets married
on a Thursday so we're out of people
actually so we're getting married this
weekend a lot of people get married on
Thursdays something I imagine if I was
getting married tonight I wouldn't be
prepared know I have too big of a
headache I woke up at the work I woke up
with a headache
um you know the worst do I know any
patches we're going to your apartment
after yeah okay so it's your last show
as a single lady is there anyone you
want to make out with anyone what do you
want to do no while do you think after I
get married in you if you made out with
someone today on the show
Zach would never know never because Ben
doesn't watch so he wouldn't tell him no
there's a chance like one of his home
friends girlfriends watches and it's
like maybe you should tell us back I
have to say something
I love the toasters because they're the
best
obviously they're the best for me of
course but last night I went to dinner
at indochine which like I used to hear
about indochine and they went there on
the Carrie Diaries like I literally know
it was still yeah and like no one showed
up
but it's so pop yeah yes it was a great
restaurant because she finally got a
serving of justice it was um packed for
Fashion Week and it's like one of those
restaurants like I say I feel like
you're always there I've been there
before
I only only once for all my birthday and
I'm like there was nothing
like if you don't eat meat I literally
ate rice my favorites so it was the best
restaurant ever but so I mean it was
poppin it was Fashion Week I was sitting
at a table and you know I was at the
table next me mr. Klein comic Calvin the
man himself like it was just poppin and
like literally these two toasters came
up to me and they were like we love the
toes and I was like me like I was
literally surrounded by like the coolest
people I got just in the restaurant and
the toasters came over to me and like
they didn't even know it but my inflated
sense of self like was just at an
all-time high
Wow and then even at the party that I
went to afterwards Paris's birthday so
many toasters at the party yes Nikki was
like when I introduced my friend so you
know I'm cool I'm like hi a friend of
Nikki Hilton I could be nice to thank
you that she's like there they love the
toes I'm like didn't he doesn't just say
the toast Wow no toasters were ablaze I
think he looks so cool in front of my
cool friends we've got toasters in here
Jesus we really didn't know there were
some mad high toasters I mean like
high-class I very fun that was just like
when we were at Bergdorf's and we were
admiring they knew Judith Leiber oh my
god because it is the most beautiful
thing I've ever seen in my life and we
are looking at these little pig and
we're like oh my god and then the woman
at the desk the counter was like oh my
god it's you guys well I said oh my god
and I was like I know it's such a cheap
Pig I thought that's what she was saying
because she's not our typical
demographic no and I was like I know
it's so cute right she goes I love you
guys and I was like if you were
recognized us due to cleaver
what you it was honestly I was like we
were thirsting out we're like four free
bags were like yeah hit us up Judith and
like we had been walking around
Bergdorf's like you know with our
backpacks in no respect yeah actually I
didn't okay but like you still got
respects up no none whatsoever
but make oh I know why I was wearing
snow boots oh yeah it was a snowy stay
ever I mean it's very hard to get
respect at Bergdorf's regardless only if
you're Beyonce but the backpack and the
snow boots really didn't help our cause
no I look I wore all my ski gear cuz I
knew I had to walk 10 blocks that day
and it was snowing so where my moon
boots I wore my ski Co because it's also
the only jacket I have that has a hood
so I was the only thing I didn't have on
with ski pants but I looked like I was
heading to the mountain no literally
with your backpack and by the way not
only that it's like he could have gotten
away with your puffer in your backpack
puffer
yellow backpack neon orange like you
were just a shining light of shape right
and then also had to take my makeup off
to get my eyelash is tinted so my skin
is 12 different colors and my eyelashes
are done and I really looks like a drug
addict but me and one of the testers
made us look cool in ten seconds so
thank you toasters per usual that's why
we give back on a day like today
Valentine's Day remember the last Mart
shop we did was my birthday because we
were just we just love celebrating you
guys on but a while it has been a while
but because it took we wanted this one
to be like really like new cool stuff
and it took us a while to come up with
different designs yeah and I just been
so busy and I'm just so excited to get
married obviously to be a wife and start
my life but also to get back to work
because planning a wedding has been
taken up like probably 7/8 of my day
every day and you know I just have so
many emails and more things that can be
doing on the toast once I'm done with my
other job that's so crazy it's like
you're gonna realize how long the days
are no I know right now I feel every day
I think about that mean that's like you
haven't as many hours in the day as
Beyonce I'm like I feel like one of
those people that's like I don't have
enough hours in the day and I never like
that oh because they used to just be
like these days are so long the line is
so long and I just used to remember like
sitting on my couch thinking about oh
wow it's only three o'clock yeah I
haven't had one of those days in a while
but I'm sure that's like a hyper
relevant for you yeah
yesterday I had a crazy day because I
did two workouts in one day and it was
and I had a really similar day like I
did no workouts in one day no but you
you supported me that's true yeah watch
your Instagram story so I felt like I
was there right so I did the live method
my final live method workout and you
know I started working on with live
method five weeks ago and I crammed 12
workouts into five weeks I think that's
pretty good plus I do a soul cycle once
a week so that's like five plus 71
workouts and then literally came home
history he was like Jackie is so skinny
when did he see it I'm sorry I don't
know you know what's so mean some of
them on my stories and like I don't even
want to talk about the one-page you know
we know she's actually a fan so she I
don't even know if that that hurts the
most
so she wrote I was doing my um things
and she goes I spy a Fupa whoo and I was
like it's just like you can't even be a
human being because my stomach yes when
I squat my stomach goes over and then up
and over
and like I literally was just floored
and I went obviously to her profile
ready to screenshot a picture and be
like you mean like this one but I
actually didn't have the time to come
get with my comeback so if you're
watching cuz I know you're a true fan
cuz the other messages to me had been
nice I don't even know if you knew how
insulting that was but it was insulting
and I'm go look at your own profile I'm
gonna zoom in on some food pose free oh
my god I'm shook to the core and then
yesterday that is the but the meanest
thing as someone who is so
self-conscious of their food but I'm
always talking about my food but if you
guys don't know Fupa stands for fat
upper pelvic area it's like right above
your vagina it's like a little belly fat
it's the most it's it's always being
exposed to her me it's like my biggest
problem I can't believe some of those
right and I don't have a Fupa complex so
it didn't bother me so much like there
I'm Noopur that she could have said no
but like when I like my stomach like I
have a little pattern I always have if I
lose weight the pouch gets smaller but
the pouch never goes away and you know
what one day it's gonna be a beautiful
home for my embryos exam children and
I'm and so for that reason I don't mind
it okay but I so it didn't like bother
me because that's not a trigger for me
but I was just like you and there's
hundreds of cut like I get so many
comments every day about people like
just so supported like you looking kind
of like just hyping me up and then it's
always just that one no I mean not only
that one that's like in most the most
evil thing anyone could say right and
and and the craziest part is I don't
even think she was an evil person no I
think like sometimes that happens like
some people just like to say stuff and
they don't realize like how the nature
of what they're saying is pure evil
right but anyways that was so that I did
live method and then there was an ariana
grande SoulCycle with Nicolas 5:30 our
favorite instructor he does musical
Mondays and he was doing an ariana
grande class so we had to go I wasn't
gonna cancel my other workout so I just
did two in one day and I was feeling it
it was really hard to do sleep last
night I slept really really great but
like some songs have a struggling the
thing you know he played seven rings and
I'm like breakfast at tiffany's and
bottles of bubbles and then he played
Thank You Neff and sent you over the
edge it sent me over the edge so it was
a great song but it was my lap I'm not
working out again until the wedding
which I'm just so excited about let the
body heal but these past five weeks have
been very very physical I've never
worked out so much in my life and you
know if you're gonna work out
the only thing you have to do is just
track every move every movement every
pound lost every inch loss ya know like
if you're gonna work out you want to get
all the credit for it like all the
pounds all the calories all the
attention so I told you guys I was using
new to just track my weight loss
journeys and it's just been so
fulfilling cuz not only do I look in the
mirror and see results but then I look
at new and I'm like oh look at me I
worked out 12 times right I live method
in five weeks and you know that's
something I can say so cool so you
should check out new it's um a
customized weight-loss training program
where you putting your information they
tell you if you tell them how much
weight you want to lose they tell you
what you should do and what like how
many calories to eat in order to achieve
your goals it's an easy 30-second online
evaluation and it shows you how much
weight you can lose and keep off it
takes the agony out of food tracking
with one of the biggest food food
databases available track your meal
habits visualize portion sizes etc all
that stuff that's like really not a
medical and like you can make mistakes
at you know even if you're trying to be
good you can make mistakes
anyways numa's design for results meet
your resolutions by signing up for your
trial today at noon and oom dot-com /
toast what do you have to lose visit new
mom / toast to start your trial today
again that's Noom dot-com / toast start
losing weight for good um I just had
something oh I wanted to let everyone
know that we recorded another patreon
episode last night we did a part two of
our teeny lexicon because there was just
so much we didn't get into and it was
really funny like I was literally in bed
last night laughing at the whole
treacherous Irish weatherman thing it
was really funny this episode is more of
just of back stories of of things that
have happened to us or things we've seen
on the internet that have just stuck
with us and there's this one video
because someone asked why do we use the
word treacherous in everyday life you
know joy let him listen on the patreon
patreon comm / the morning toast oh my
god and when I went to go find the video
I was crying me too the crust milena oh
my god I don't want to spoil the video
for you guys know you take risks on
treacherous roads just swim in the sea
oh my god it's so funny Pedro and I cam
session morning toast and then today we
are doing an episode you and I about my
wedding so if you have questions about
that you know how I've just remained a
beacon of hope
and an insanity during a dark time
please join patreon.com session wearing
toe so you joined the Facebook group
that accompanies it you ask any question
you want and at some point we will get
to it that's what we do is answer
questions this is so true ok so busy day
busy Phillips we're gonna recap New
Jersey after we do the fast 5 stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
ok you know what I actually I need a sip
I just spoke so much ok I'll talk for a
little I'm feeling so hungover like and
I wasn't even that [ __ ] up actually no
I was what time did you get home not too
late I was in bed by 1:00 do Paris like
her gate she open in front of you ok so
I was Jackie helped me fine I get for
Paris cuz like what do you get the girl
that has everything like when you say
the girl that has everything you're
talking about pax it's like actually the
girl that has everything and so when we
wrap her dress I got her the [ __ ]
cutest one of the things we were talking
with the Judith Leiber one but like
obviously those bags start like $5,000 I
got like the little tiny um pillow pill
box and it was a cute little rainbow ice
cream covered in crystals it was so cute
and she open and she thought it was so
cute yeah yeah it was good I love giving
like good s4l ok first story ariana
grande recorded alternate Thank You next
in case she married Pete Davidson
someone just told me this Marco told me
well I haven't read this swear yet so I
look forward to hearing the details and
what the Balearic would have been
because it's um I thought up a Shawn but
it wasn't in a Matt oh here we go
wrote some songs about Tiggy now I
listen and laugh even almost got married
and for Pete I'm so thankful so what
could it have been and I'm really
married what maybe maybe the article
citizen angel Castillo is an angel yes
that song is I mean it's an incredible
song but it's even better when you
realize it's about dr. Theo for Chapman
it's even better when you realize you've
been singing it wrong it's not thank you
next it's Thank You Neff and I was going
through our wedding band list and like I
really want them to play thank you next
but it's a very inappropriate song to
play at a wedding oh my god yeah but
what if I could ask them to sing Thank
You Ness Thank You Man
your band is literally gonna quit the
day before with all your debate I have a
few like demands where it's like in out
of where no it's like I want them to
play [ __ ] better have my money but like
that's kind of you know they said you
see [ __ ] a lot so it's like can you
just see snitch instead after they say
yes um and no one we're like I didn't
see any red flag so I think it might
have made it oh that's so funny so funny
just a couple personalized touches
that's very personalized Thank You next
accelerate the rise of Ariana Grande's
already ascent ascendant career it was
the first number one it was her first
number one on the Billboard Hot 100
served as the launching point for one of
granny's most successful projects and
proved that a pop star looking to hip
hop over her inspiration in the Streamy
age could pay immense dividends was this
written by CNN business no right look
dividends during an interview on Zach
sang show Grande describes how nerves
about including the names of her exes
I'm thinking next inspired her
experiment expired inspired her to
experiment with different lyrics we had
like three different versions of the
song ground they said I'm like super shy
when it comes to pitching wild things so
I was like is it insane if I mean people
and thank them directly in the song tell
me round a thanking ex producer
infrequent croc Grande collaborator
explained in the interview that all the
people in the studio knew the original
version was the version they should use
but grimy needed to try different
approaches Ariana's careful not to
mention Pete Davidson's name but alludes
to a potential marriage that affected
the song in my relationship at the time
things were like up and down and on and
off and so I didn't know what was going
to happen and then we got back together
so I had to make a different version of
it and then we broke up again so we
ended up going with that verse there's a
version where I was getting married
there's a version where I'm not getting
married there's a version with nothing
we're not talking about anything but we
all knew that the first verse was gonna
be the version we ultimately went with I
spent a lot of time with each of those
people learning and bleeped expletive Oh
probably [ __ ] yeah
Ariana said is she began to tear up it
was scary to put in a song with wood
she's younger tell us what the verses
right so now we have to infer so even
almost got math and now I'm getting
married and prepared I'm so thankful
wish I could say thank you to CEO
because he wasn't it
he was an angel yesterday maybe today
he'll be a monster no he's sister
precious gentleman such a precious gem
of a man I want to put him on a necklace
and wear him around my neck he's such a
precious gem he's a social person I love
him I love him more that's crazy to me
cuz I love him so much and I know you
love him more and so it's like how is
that even possible you know the heart
expands it's a muscle no it's actually
really crazy because I feel like I'm
such a different person than the person
I was without a dog because my heart is
so full and big now yeah I'm so much
kinder I think he's softened me up
it's crazy um also you know what I was
thinking about ariana grande because I
was listening to a lot of her new music
while I was in SoulCycle yesterday at
the ariana grande themed ride and like
it's very sexual considering she's like
oh I con for so many young girls like
there's so many look at what's on dress
no but she's always just talking about
like um like even break up with you
that's what I was gonna say break up
with your girlfriend is a little raunchy
you can hit it in the money
ya know just saying but I mean she is
like a 26 year old woman so what else is
she gonna sing about so you can hit it
in the morning right good it's like you
know her 13 year old fans are you can
hit it in the morning totally they're
like hit what a piata that's always so
funny just like 13-year old singing bone
Appetit right they don't even know
they're talking about needing someone's
size like bread I can't with that so
that song was so hardball that was a
really dark time for Katy Perry and like
her whole camp there should be a Razzies
for music like the Grammy Razzies and
just have katy perry hosted over you
know and like the worst songs of the
year cuz there are some really [ __ ]
terrible ones like that would have won
for that year hmm but there are some
really bad songs that people put out
they think that's like what people watch
[ __ ] that one two is up there another
one a the best it i should kinda like it
do I think I don't like it when I hear a
bone Appetit like I I get like I cringe
in that video of her performing it with
whoever's in it oh that's terrible
okay next story the breaking this
morning I hadn't heard of it until I
read the headline so I don't know the
story beyond the headlines
just you know reading it with you guys
many more speaks about her alleging ex
Ryan Adams was psychologically abusive
in a new report musician Ryan Adams is
facing allegations of harassment and
emotional abuse by his ex-wife Mandy
Moore and six other women the new york
times like did a [ __ ] number on ryan
adams they had man jenny moore speaking
they had some messages i don't even know
how they got it
he's been apparently been like online in
like music like fandom chats like
chatting with fourteen-year-old girls
like sexually for years and what makes
this whole thing weird is I'm a little
upset at Taylor Swift because I would
have went my entire life no not knowing
who Ryan Adams I was like not even
hearing his name like who but I did
become familiar with him when he
released an entire album that was just
he released in 1989 a cover album of
Taylor Swift's entire album from front
front to back and that's when I figured
out who he was and became aware I'm like
oh he's married to me anymore but I
could have gone my whole life without
knowing yeah um I agree and you know
what I remember when that album came out
never I was like I got read out of a
test session and like I was sick oh my
god write Madame's and I listened to it
he's [ __ ] Terra but I didn't even
listen to it but it's like that's just a
weird thing to do like come up with your
own and everyone's so excited and it's
like okay you guys never talked about
Ryan Adams before or after yet you're so
excited Bryan Adams has to be the one to
cover this album right it's so weird
I just loved imitating people me too
madam oh my god no same honestly that
okay so wait so finish the article what
does she start it Mandy Moore is
speaking out after a Wednesday New York
Times story in which she and six other
women accused her ex-husband musician
Ryan Adams of harassment and emotional
abuse in the article Moore who has
previously opened up about her difficult
marriage to met Adams they Wed in 2009
and divorced in 2016 said her ex has
been now 44 took charge of her music
career in 2010 three years after they
first met when she was 23 now this is aa
star claimed he quote discouraged her
from working with other producers and
managers but after writing songs
together Adams would quote replace her
with other female artists when it take
came time to record the tracks the
actress was said also said he was
psychologically abusive and belittled
her musical abilities his controlling
behavior essentially did block my
ability to make new connections in the
industry during a very pivotal and
potentially the potentially lucrative
time my entire mid to late 20s she told
the Times Adams denied Moore's claims
via his lawyer saying her
characterization of their relationship
is completely inconsistent with his view
of course it's inconsistent with his
view because he's a monster right a
monsters view is always different than
he regular monsters view is never
consistent quote speaking of truth can
be painful and triggering but it's
always worth it she wrote on Instagram
after the article was published my heart
is with all the women who have suffered
any sort of trauma or abuse you are seen
and heard quote hashtag sisterhood
forever so the weird thing about this is
that the New York Times actually had
some of the messages he was sending
people online and while he said he liked
often alluded to sexual activities he
also said something really weird he was
like one of the messages and don't quote
me it's not word for word but was like
people are gonna think I'm like are
Kelly yeah when did he say that like
recently mmm I don't know but it was
just in the New York Times I saw it on
Twitter made a quote card and it's going
around ooh yeah it was Pittsville but
then that also is just like so everyone
knew about our Kelly because Brian Adams
is talking to strangers about it on
Instagram right did everyone know about
Ryan Adams you know think anyone even
knew Ryan Adams to begin with you know
the thing is it's like and what the New
York Times article said is like he would
be he would like trade sexual favors for
the promise of like career furthering a
book our County yeah but like what the
hell can Ryan Adams do for you
all right I know is no I think like okay
I think right now Miz is like one of
those people it's either like you don't
know who he is or you're a big fan of
his there's no in-between where he's
just like a celebrity who people like a
musician who people enjoy right but like
are Kelly telling people that like they
continue he can change their lives
musically like ah that's believable like
he had the power to do that at a period
of time like he made aliyah like he he
was very powerful and influential in in
music but so if someone was like Ryan
Adams if you do this for him he'll give
you a record deal I may be like what
Ryan Adams record deal
what's his label right okay I'm thinking
maybe Ryan Adams is what like a like not
a pretty sure bit of song right or maybe
he's like more of a behind the scene
like a Ryan Tedder right I'm really
confusing the two event but I'm just
gonna say I love Ryan Tedder so much me
I think he's hot as hell I think there
needs to be I'm big
steaming pile of justice served for one
Republic and so funny I was already
talking about this with Margo yesterday
you know those videos always pop up on
Facebook like a random like interview
stitch together like how cute her Anna
Kendrick you know like a knowing [ __ ]
like that there was one about Adele
whatever and she was they had a clip of
her at the Grammys and at making her
speech and behind her was Ryan Tedder
and I was like Ryan Tedder wrote on a
gels album and then so I went so Ryan
Tedder I googled like Grammy nominations
and wins so he won for 1989 with Taylor
I didn't know he wrote that he won 425
Adele he was a writer on a Beyonce album
he literally writes forever I'm like the
best of the best
no he's unbelievably talented I saw him
this summer they opened for Zac Brown
Band which was just such an interesting
combination but very in tune with what's
necessary and I'm obsessed with One
Republic like I can do Alexa play One
Republic and listen to it for hours on
end that's so smart I've never thought
to do it but I just want to say like the
controversial statement coming out you
native is one of the best albums of the
last 10 years I agree this is life in
color no what's that other one something
good no other / you put it on I just
like I [ __ ] actually don't put on for
more than seven seconds because this
episode will get taken down is the song
from that album that's like something
good something big it's like uh this was
something hold on hold on and you know
what I won't play because you know you
can you can sing it okay yeah yeah
better than the rest of them hold on
where's freaking OneRepublic see guys I
can't even find the most powerful I
lived
I did it all their songs are so you know
flexible they're so transcendent like
they could be in car commercials but
they can also be like in the background
of a video that's gonna be he like cry
or like you know they're just so
inspirational right and then there's
also secrets which has the most
beautiful opening you know it you know
it yeah I mean that didn't ring any
bells but I'm sure it sound something
like that it sounds nothing like that of
course what is that song that I'm
thinking okay I'm on the native album um
cuz yeah yes you've got something I need
in this world full of people there's one
killing me and if I only died once hey I
wanna die with you ooh beautiful if you
listen to one song after us recommending
a million to you over the course of the
toast listen to something I need by
OneRepublic it's a song like when you're
listening to it it makes you feel a
bunch of things the first is like I'm
gonna get my life together I'm gonna be
the man I'm gonna go to the gym I'm
gonna reconnect with my sister on
television I love Jackie older sister
right Satan just a few other love runs
out if you ever watch anything on TGI T
yeah
I'm in church you know this what's the
song when I was a kid my father was a
preacher
wow this album I didn't realize how much
our is how much we listened to it there
was like a year where it was like what
we listened to exclusively I remember it
was my senior year in college personally
it's such like this album cover look
like is it blue with the nail or not the
blue with the colors is this one which
is also incredible yeah that's the
waking up album it's just one Republic
needs some justice I think we should go
to a concert yeah there's actually one
coming up and I'll tell you about it and
what's so crazy about one Republic is
like they have one of the biggest songs
of all time the one that Alesso did and
made it into like it was a slow song
that he made it into um something I mean
yeah it's like
oh wait just give me a second I got it
okay I'm gonna search Ellis and wonder
public just in case even yeah it's um I
want to see the word myself is in the
title if I lose myself I lose my cell to
memory um also a li mu ha just came out
with the best idea of all time that we
need to release it now toast CD yeah and
you know what what else we're gonna put
on there some [ __ ] Goo Goo Dolls
justice for the [ __ ] Goo Goo Dolls
Jackie said the Goo Goo Dolls in concert
I know they came to Colgate and everyone
was probably icons came to Colgate Goo
Goo Dolls we have this week on hot
spring party weekend where they bring in
like a performer but it's usually either
someone on the rise or someone on the
decline so they brought in Goo Goo Dolls
one year one year they brought uh vici
what so I've seen a beachy you did yes
oh my god you know this one I brought
shaggy one year they brought b.o.b b.o.b
and he was who he was our sophomore year
so like we were just having that time
and then they brought memmer when you
guys came in with someone with um Oh
Lupe Fiasco who baby ask oh wait that's
so crazy
look at Fiasco was only when I went to
it honestly it wasn't lit now we have a
good time because we were being steamy
but I'll just waiting for that one song
right now create like lights or some
whatever um that's so crazy I can't live
you saw BJ you know I never saw beachy I
took a trip when I was a senior in high
school to Puerto Rico and like I was
barely allowed to go like let alone
everyone was there were so everyone was
leaving the resort to go to a concert
and I was like I'm not even gonna ask
because I know I won't be allowed like
are you kidding like leaving leaving the
hotel I was like I just gotten
permission Olivia wasn't allowed to go
on that trip or CT air did you go yeah
so I was the first kid allowed to go I
just like I didn't even ask me I knew I
wouldn't be allowed and everyone went
except for me my friend Elise yeah I cuz
she also wasn't allowed to go and now we
just you know we hold grudges because we
never got to see AVG live thanks Dan
yeah uh I was gonna say one more person
that came Oh
remember that DJ that we both used to be
obsessed with Jesse Jesse Marcus yeah he
and he does all those mashups
yeah he came to Colgate one time and I
was obsessed than I told you guys have
you were like oh my god me my friends
are obsessed with him we follow him all
around the city I mean where is he now I
don't know we should go see him at marki
oh great miss his hat okay your missus
hat today not just today ladies
okay next story Prince Phillip won't be
prosecuted for the car crash that
injured two women you know we never
talked about that car crash on this show
but you know it was it was a car in
ninety eight year old man who got into a
car accident and is just fine right so
they say feel that they definitely in
Prince Philip like body doubles yeah but
the two ladies what happened to them so
days after Buckingham Palace announced
that Prince Philip is giving up his
driver's license
what's decision so Prince Philip and I
have something in common we both don't
have our license and we both are in love
with the Queen that's Jim British
authorities said Thursday that the Duke
of Edinburgh won't be prosecuted for a
crash that injured two women the 97 year
old husband of Queen Elizabeth the
second was driving a Land Rover near the
Royal Family's Sandringham Estate when
he slammed into another car in January
17th
the other driver a 28 year old woman
suffered cuts to her knee while a 45
year old woman passenger in the car
which also had a nine month baby on
board broke her wrist
we took into account all the
circumstances in this case including the
level of culpability the age of the
driver and the surrender of the driver's
license the Crown Prosecution Service
said in the statement on Thursday we
have decided that would not be in the
public interest to prosecute Jackie he
snapped her wrist and he stole her coke
re-ack if she was pregnant that's
terrible could've been so much worse so
pregnant she was had a baby no nine
months pregnant or not a baby on board
Oh is he okay yeah okay it seems um yeah
I mean does it am i shocked at the crowd
has decided not to persecute the Prince
like no obviously
nepotism the ninety eight year old
Prince ya know it's like you know how
I'm like if a really old or sick person
and like kill someone they like don't
prosecute yeah I think that's like a
nice law do you know it depends on the
brutality of the murder it's just so
like weird it's it is it's weird that
that's a thing like if you murder
someone but you also happen to be in
hospice you get off yeah that's like
spoiler alert in Desperate Housewives
when Karen McCluskey took the the fall
because she was on her way to the
hospice I think she actually like died
next day and she said it was her to get
them out of the sweetie that was so
sweet I loved that that was like such a
nice way to end her arc on the show and
any time there was something bad
like the the town was in danger I'm like
Karen McCluskey's gonna be the one that
can hurt now is her time because she was
like this old lady and she was sick in
the beginning and then she was like
healthy so it was just like when is her
time and she went out in a really you
know unifying way she coexisted she
coexisted no she coalesced okay
next story if I can get there Apple is
targeting April to launch its new video
service but Netflix won't be a part of
it and HBO is in doubt
Apple is targeting April to debut a new
streaming product that will include
original content free for Apple device
owners and a platform to describe to
other digital media services HBO hasn't
signed on to the service yet but still
may do so Netflix and Hulu aren't
expected to be part of the channel
service so I mean what's going on in the
streaming industry right now it's the
streaming horse is capitalism at its
finest it's like they're all out here
trying to make the best platform with
the best content and the most reasonable
price just because there's competition
and I'd love it you know it's like as a
consumer it's like I'm getting Netflix
is like a really socking and I'm getting
ready to [ __ ] cancer right like when
I pay for it I would cancel its love 11
make-a-wish just for the girls justice
for the girls justice for the girls
peaceful and happy wonderful wedding
weekend peaceful and happy and wonderful
wedding weekend please all that happy
and wonderful my time weekend and people
are happy wonderful wedding weekend
where I look beautiful it's gonna happen
you don't need 1111 Kylie's closet
Kylie's closet Kylie's closet Kylie's
closet you have your scarf you have your
scarf you have your scarf you have you
sorry yeah what should I wish for next
dream bigger totally err me Iraqi army
screw em he's cracker musica um what
were you talking about
successful merged a sucessful merge a
successful merged a successful merged a
when I'm saying this right Wow should
the streaming wars oh yeah I'm just
loving the the thriving there's no
monopoly like this is like when you were
learning like in school like what
capitalism was like what monopoly was I
can history class Rockefellers yeah like
this is high trust laws yeah like this
is it it's like everyone's out here
trying to make the best product and it's
like every time there's like a glitch or
a problem it gets fixed because you
don't want to be the streaming service
with the problem right but Hulu is
really coming up like now when I go like
I usually troll Netflix watch a few
trailers can't decide what to watch I
then go to Hulu okay you know it who
introduced me to the greatest Christmas
and
I ever saw it's called a Cinderella
Christmas and for them and they had the
better fire festival documentary and
they had a savage launch about it and so
what they have integrity and they
[ __ ] had Desperate Housewives that's
what I was gonna say so I only started
using Hulu because definitely had
integrity - Bret's that's important in
the stream Wars the Desperate Housewives
is on it and so now I go to Hulu but I
have a big problem with Hulu it's just
that their app isn't quite as
navigatable or user-friendly it's like
if you're watching something you pause
like the TV whatever when you come back
they don't tell you where you were
yeah it's very confusing also they don't
like tell me things I should watch like
I have to go it's not discoverability
for a new programming isn't great like I
have to seek it out I kind of like that
it's like Netflix is always suggesting
trash oh they get offended I'm like you
think I want to watching this right I'm
a loser I think I want to watch a visa
right um also prime video is really
really up there we started marvelous
Miss Basel no oh my god I feel like I
haven't spoken about it because everyone
the second it came out do you watch
Mazal it's a girl she's a Jewish
comedian yeah and for a while it was
just like no I don't want to watch it
then they did a huge Instagram campaign
and paid literally every single person
in the world to advertise it except for
uh the Jewish comedian and I was just
like bitter about it but then I was like
eh I got to see what it's about when it
wasn't all the SAG Awards I was like
okay you know what I'm gonna watch it
and I saw Rachel Brosnahan
deliver like a cute speech and I was
like okay even though I do think she's
annoying and I'm only like I'm like
halfway through the first season and
might after the first episode I stopped
and I was like I can't believe so many
people want to tell me they'll watch a
show furthermore I can't believe so many
Jewish people told me to watch a show
because there is definitely an
anti-semitic undertone to the show
I'm just I'm gonna put it out there and
I know Rachel Cross and Jewish like how
can they be and that's not it's just
like all like the Jewish stereotypes
that they play off of which are
definitely like legit like a are real
like things Jewish people say and do but
they exaggerate it so much to the point
of like okay so it's like she has a
newborn baby and the grandmother it's
freaking out that the baby's forehead is
too big that she hates the baby because
the baby's far heads too big I'm like
are you that we could ever having a
Jewish grandmother whenever she doesn't
see one day when I see one flaw murderer
but you be like yeah but look at his
skin
it was just like and it was just taking
these stereotypes so far and I was I was
really like affected I was like this is
[ __ ]
I didn't like it okay somebody you kept
watching I kept watching just because
this stand-up part of it as someone who
like literally just decided to get into
stand-up just like the character does
like it's really interesting like the
first time she bomb she does like the
sense of a Ted I mean she was like the
audience was terrible and they were like
her manager was like no you were
terrible like apparently the manager is
great she's I mean she's a sticky brown
noser with a hidden agenda I mean I
can't believe that the principle from
the Lizzie McGuire remover literally
took 30 years off miss umbrage what's
her name yeah I'm great I'm rich she's a
sneaky brown noser with a hidden agenda
I mean I can't believe she about that
she's Jewish to her characters I don't
think it's Jewish
it's just they definitely the music and
the clothes are amazing like they really
I think captured what New York was like
in the 50s I think it's supposed to be
and there's a lot of things about it
that I like but she is in sufferable oh
my god the way she just like butts
around yeah I want to kill her there's
characters that I like her dad scares me
it's just honestly I'm not hooked
whatsoever I keep forgetting I watched
old season two is better I believe you
said I do want to start it but you know
what I mean these days I'm really busy
maybe I'll feel differently in a week
but like I don't have time for anything
that isn't gonna enhance my life than
that I have to like suffer through in
order to enjoy something that I'm
suffering through it's like when I go to
my TV when I was watching Desperate
Housewives I knew exactly where to go it
was muscle memory go to Hulu I literally
days go by I forget that I'm watching I
go I'll watch an episode it's just it's
not captivating whatsoever I'm surprised
that like there's such like a love for
cuz I'm really the person like who
should love it or maybe or the person
who shouldn't like it's like you're
you're too close to it
you know and it's like anytime someone
makes something like about you're like
parallel to what you're doing you're
like no it should be this way that way
that's you know yeah no I just think
like they nail some things when it like
how like Kathy Hilton didn't watch
American woman right that's true I was
just why I killed her I was watching the
Beverly Hills um reviewing in before
shows once so I was remembering all that
stuff about the show like that dramas
crazy and then she was making another
show about the actual drama that
happened in the reality I'm sorry in the
Realty world with her family yeah and I
recommend we got cancelled right yeah so
all that for nothing
yeah actually we watched a few episodes
cuz when to the premiere it was good it
was really good and now I have two
sweatshirts from the premiere because I
took yours and I wear them all the time
and now they're piece of history so
that's exciting for me as a history
major there's an final story before we
get to the fun stuff meet the billion
dollar media investor behind Gwyneth
Paltrow's goop and Lady Gaga's beauty
start-up and really the story here is
Lady Gaga has a beauty startup question
mark Lightspeed Venture Partners Nicole
Quinn talks about the controversy
surrounding goop and my female led
businesses are finally getting the
recognition they deserve what's the
controversy strongest brands will stand
the test of time I think the controversy
around goop is that it's so like
hoity-toity right but it does well so
who hurts
yeah but they like sell rocks for $17 or
maybe that's bleep lively site preserve
yeah no they sell like face masks for
$300 but there are rich women in the
Hamptons who need them right and you
know it doesn't work because um I'll do
anything for a good face mask right but
but a rock no I mean she is so funny and
so smart like that conscious uncoupling
thing like what's the most genius
marketing thing ever
yeah and by the way do you think
everyone realizes goop is GP Gwyneth
Paltrow and what's the - oh it's just
like our initials so if you were gonna
say her initials OOP I think oh that
would make a lot of sense as though yeah
I mean I have the worst initials so okay
so this is an interview with this
venture capitalist Nicole Quinn I would
like to see her on Shark Tank Lee knows
I'm gonna say also uh
she looks female lead and owned
businesses hi oh yeah that's really why
no I really wanted to hear a lot more
about Lady Gaga startup but you know
what this article is just way too long
I'm gonna have to enjoy it on my own
they talked about Sofia Moreau so it
seems like a really great you know
clique of ladies who are just crushing
it I need to get in that crew yeah
definitely I think we have to work a
little harder
like we're not there yet yeah no married
all right and then I'll have the time to
anything else no totally after this
merch shot maybe we'll see marriage
marriage marriage okay so it wasn't
really a story no because like it's it's
an interview and I really just wanted to
hear about Lady Gaga's beauty startup
oh my god you know I've heard the most
interesting article in Esquire I think
it was okay so they're doing this
profile series on like just different
people growing up and different like
lives I don't know I don't really get
what the series is but
just profiled this like random teenager
Ryan
sorry 17 years old senior in high school
lives in like like 30 minutes outside
Madison Wisconsin like really like the
middle of the country and it was just
like so interesting it was kind of
political and I don't really understand
that the whole political side of it but
he was saying so he was outside the
computer lab one day he like it's his
life was shook up by this incident last
year where he got in trouble and the
incident was he was standing outside the
computer lab standing next to school and
he was like fiddling with the door like
being and making an annoying sound and
the girl was like stop but he didn't
he'd kept going just fiddling the
doorknob the girl slapped him in the
face he slapped her back in the face and
then he had to go to like a court like
not court but like school court and he
got in a lot of trouble and really shook
him up and he was like if if if I was a
girl but I've gotten the same punishment
no it was just an interesting article
there's gonna have to go to school Clara
trail I don't know but there's just the
articles getting a lot of backlash and
I'm just like I was following along on
this Esquire series um I don't know I
thought it was kind of interesting
okay we'll share it in the groups I was
sharing different and we can do you know
toast article of the week we're sharing
different um content it was such a long
article I was like yeah and this girl
had to go with him to Madison and then
go to the parents house who like their
divorce he lives not like literally in
the Ozarks and like damn the script
works hard and like you know she makes
no money for this article you know right
but we're talking about on the top so
yeah it's little justice it was just
such a weird article Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills I'm sorry New Jersey oh
yeah we already spoke about Beverly
Hills right yeah oh yeah in depth even
though like not that much happens but
we're just really spoke about our
excitement for with yeah you know what I
did do last night I've read some of the
blog's I read Kyle's blog I read Teddy's
blog what did Kyle says Kyle said she
explained the whole situation of the
tomtom Daily Mail party what'd you say
um so she said that she received an
invite to the to the Daily Mail party at
Tom Tom and it came from Daily Mail so
it's just their party it happened to be
a Tom Tom as far as she knew Tom Tom
wasn't open yet and so she wasn't
planning on going could she been in
Europe with her kids by the time she got
back it would have been four a.m. their
time but she thought you know what maybe
let me just call Lisa and make sure
that's okay with her because she's the
type of person imma get upset about that
she calls Lisa um I saw this party Daily
Mail like what do you have to do with it
and she was like oh no darling like the
tom-toms not even open yet
it's a daily mail party like don't come
we don't face and so then she didn't and
then Lisa used it against her and then
that's why Kyle was like I knew you were
gonna [ __ ] do this like that's why
she literally called her good um she
really and then she said oh my god this
was a most interesting card she was like
the Ted the dog
Johnny Vanderpump dog I don't know what
his name is I'm gonna call him Johnny
Jonathan John she was like they really
wanted they did this whole show at song
and dance they really wanted to talk
about the story then in there and tell
me about it like even though Lisa was
pretending they didn't have to bring
that dog out that day of all the dogs
are in the back okay so Teddy's said
pretty much the same thing she said two
interesting things when she was just
like giving us updates on her
friendships with everyone and she was
like I've really come so far with
everyone except for Joey but like she
her and Kyle are like best friends like
they hang out every day I thought that
was interesting too she said my
relationship with John was being so
exaggerated we're not best friends she's
like I've literally spoken to him a
couple times because he's Lisa's like
representative right because they're
doing a charity idea right but Lisa for
Lisa's narrative it it makes more sense
if Ted if Teddy and whatever the
relationship she was like police that
was so exaggerated I'm just like
co-workers with him then she also said
by now if if Lisa doesn't want something
brought up it doesn't get brought up
like that whole acting of no don't she
was like and why would the dog be
brought out on the exact day that were
all they are do you how many dogs there
are that are there right and also if
this dog has like a propensity for
fighting biting children like and
they're bringing their kids for shows
like the dog actually shouldn't be there
couldn't agree more lisa is a [ __ ]
actress you know what she should be a
nominees for an Oscar because she really
she have you really had me fooled
oh my god hold it i from I don't know
legally Vaughn Vivian OH
when she sees Natalia almost had me oh
yeah you had me fooled you almost had me
fooled
okay so but no sorry New Jersey now hi
I'm Jimmy blanket statement for a new
here at San Jose let me get this out
there Margaret Joseph's my hero
me too my hero I'm really struggling no
when it comes to the sides because
Jennifer like I love her I love her
house I actually think she has a good
marriage with her husband even though
everyone's trying to like make it seem
like it's something that it's not I
think they just have like they come from
a culture where it's like you stay with
your man and they have like a good
respectful I mean they were out to
dinner her oldest daughter is a good kid
yeah when
was so excited to be at the party alone
like I was loving her so excited she's
like sorry you have so many kids like
for kids to feel special especially the
oldest one she's her kids are so cute no
and I was like I wanna babysit I was
loving the older one like I was really
just like impressed by her she was very
mature and I just really liked her I
think she has a good thing going like
everyone judges and makes comments about
her arranged marriage whatever even
Melissa said that yesterday like I don't
know I like her and her family know I
love her in your family and it's so
interesting to witness people who are
who are different than it right right
look our house
I knew it like Theo came from the old
country where this like arranged
marriage just happened all the time and
you know people never got divorced yeah
so there's something to be said no I
just think they have a nice thing going
on and I don't judge um and it's just
she's so on the wrong side and it's
bothering me so much because I like her
so much can't blame her for being on the
wrong side though because I think still
like maybe now things have changed but
in this episode and where they were on
the show like Margaret and Melissa I
don't think they really like get
Jennifer yet and they don't really like
her so even if she was like I want to be
on this side like they haven't even
asked her to be yeah resent her like
they both have like old school mentality
or traditional values so it's like even
if she went to the other side she's not
even welcome there that's so I don't
blame her for being on the side and it's
not like she's blindly following
Danielle and later what was so crazy
last night was when Danielle said
something to Teresa you're Teresa's you
say Giudice nobody tells you who to be
friends with and who you can hang around
and then she comes back and she's like
nobody tells me who to be friends with
it and hang around it was like literally
watching someone be manipulated and you
know that Danielle is capable of it and
it's like we just saw how that Sun where
she's talking to the girls she was like
oh you don't want her around okay I
won't bring her around you guys like
yeah okay she goes outside they don't
want to be around you you're Teresa
Giudice nobody tells them you her to
bring around she comes back in nobody
tell me who to bring around you're right
and and like it was it was a weird it
was so crazy to watch someone being
manipulated like that in ten minutes and
I just have to say like I tried I just
can't get with Jackie first of all I
won't say her mom looked so good what
that woman did to her mom's hair was
magic she looked amazing that was a
really sweet scene I'm not buying this
whole sister thing I think it's really
weird for 15 years the only time you're
gonna reconnect with your sister is
I think it's really weird I think it's
weird and it's here's the like if it
were margaret reconnecting with his
sister it's like I'm invested in
Margaret and her life in her store she's
been so open and or anyone even Teresa
Melissa going after pursuing a new
sister I care about these people like
Jackie I just met her season why don't
care about her estranged sister yet like
I when it's someone's for incoming
storyline like and you want us to care
one about this person and then about
your extended 15 years worth of
backstory like no first I need to love
this person in order to care about
what's going on with them it's not so
true even Jennifer's storyline like it
was about her brothers arranged marriage
but it was so interesting like her going
to Turkey and and all the culture of it
you know cross but if you but it's so
saying you took out like that that
cultural aspect and it's just her
brothers getting engaged and I'm what
I'm watching Jennifer's brother getting
H I barely know Jennifer like total a
first season storyline if someone's
personal life has to be more interesting
not only that it's like it begs the
question of like why are you doing this
why do you go on t bright-eyed anything
like that yes sir like weird my question
was why do you Bravo think that I care
and my question is don't you think this
time is weird and that's a great
question I don't know and it's so when
she's like and I should love her because
I love Marg and Melissa like I love them
and love their husbands I loved the
whole thing and Jackie loves it just as
much as I do she wants in and she's
defending Margaret he's on the right
side she says the right things some
reason I just don't believe it like I
don't know there's something about her
and I really like on TV and off TV like
love Margaret and I love Melissa they've
always been nothing but so kind to us
I'm seeing Margaret next week like I
love the car yeah I'm it's a surprise
Latoya later surprise for me no I think
I know it already yeah is it yeah yeah
so I think I don't know I just I just
love her like and I trust her so she
they love Jackie and there's something
about Jackie that seems a little just in
genuine that I can't I can't put my
finger on but it's like she's sitting
here saying I'm I'm gonna judge someone
based on how they treat me but also how
they treat my friends which is an
excellent point
just physio nice to me but mean to my
friend I don't have to be nice to you
like I know you're treating my friend
and that's like a housewives thing it's
like are you nice to people because
they're nice to you like it was a really
smart
thing to say she's a good friend and
when she told her mom she's like mom I
reconnect with my sister like the whole
thing was just like lacking genuine like
feeling when it comes to the whole
sister thing like I'm out on Jackie when
it comes to her having good judgment
within the group I'm in on her yeah and
I like her in her husband I think
they're very husband is so hot they have
a really cute relationship great kids
are cute they're like a strong family
unit and that I'd rather see more about
that see more about how she orders
catering instead of cooking for her
family yeah it's hilarious no it's so
cute and her husband is so cute and she
does great clam there's just something I
think she's just too self-aware and is
trying to be too in control of the image
she's putting forth but you really can't
on reality TV like it's in someone
else's hands but even when she was here
I felt I felt as if she would had a wall
up you know yeah well he wants she lets
us see only what she wants us to see
right but it's like show us other side
you know we'll still love you yeah like
I think the fans are very understanding
yeah
Jennifer's party looks so fun like I
just was thinking like if I was there
but so my type of party like nobody
crowded gambling tables with fake money
like bar pool like that's so my vibe so
my I really like I really love her she's
come out so strong this season and that
sign up any hana was just a sir and I
might have said like she was my number
one this season but Margaret and her
husband pushing Marty into the pool not
even above it was fully Margaret well
you know was weird
it's like they had cameras on the scene
the whole time and they like cut out
like the three seconds where you could
actually see who was the person pushing
him yeah they like skin it was weird
yeah I boomeranged it and it went black
for a second like it was weird
it's it's almost like the battery died
for just one second or there's something
that they didn't want us to see and then
it was like they push him in but I have
certain boiling you know you're being
pushed into a pool you you jump because
um you don't want like hit your head
like yeah when you grab the person but
then it looked like the way that he
falls into the pool almost looks like a
pencil yeah that's not how someone
though you lean back
that's not how someone could fall into a
pool it's almost like they push him into
the pool but they didn't get it so they
did it again or something like that I
don't know because the way that he
thought Ellen was like because it's he
was in the shallow end yeah
and I understand him like getting
control of the way he falls into the
pole but he would never be able to be
upright like that something about the
quantum physics of it all was off agreed
and to me maybe it was like they missed
it yeah and they filmed it again well so
I don't know that's that could be wrong
few things to say it's just so funny and
I really can't wait to see the reunion
because Danielle and Marty are divorced
now and not only that she [ __ ] hates
him now so I want to see how she's gonna
defend herself because they were a unit
at the time what Marty said was so vile
and so discussing and what he said at
milania's was so vile and disgusting he
deserve to be pushing the ball and then
again your wife has no tits I mean just
on a basic human level what are you a
third grader we're talking about the
size of boobs first of all second of all
Margaret has great tits and they're real
so please [ __ ] off second of all you're
gonna you're a grown man you have
children and you're talking about your
friends wife's tits real friend but
really I was shocked the fact that they
didn't punch him in the face and like
just you just first of all you can't
speak about a woman that way like as a
man in this climate and just in general
you can't second of all you can't speak
about an older mature respect in women
like that like it makes it so much worse
three a woman whose husband is your foot
right like those are insults they would
sling on Siesta case ya know on the
playground right it's like he's a
two-year-old yeah I was shot and it's
like you
Marty anything I'll have a real issue
with Margaret like truly and when when
confronted when Jo and Margaret are
confronting him like you want to talk
about my wife and all he can say is
she's the reason why the reason why they
don't get along is cuz my wife's
beautiful and your wife's not like
that's the best you have Lee that Marty
is a wealthy man he must be smart in
some way just actually I don't know
about wealthy whatever does he actually
think in his brain that these two grown
women are fighting because one of them
is jealous of the others boobs I don't
know but you know what the way I saw
Theresa get manipulated imagine what
Marty's been through no that was just
ten minutes and when Margaret was here
she said something really interesting
she said Marty's been sleeping on
someone's couch what did she say
and then the publicist told her to be
quiet on her couch margaret was saying
that Theresa said it Theresa said it
okay Theresa said that now Marty is
sleeping on Margaret
ouch because clearly Margaret and Joe
have taken Marty's side in the divorce
if so not only have they forgiven him
but now they're like you know take
harbor of him harboring a fugitive
yeah the reunion is gonna be so
interesting because of the dynamic that
Margaret that Marty and Danielle are
divorced and you know who's really kind
of an interesting character is Dolores
because she's friends mostly with
everyone but she doesn't blatantly just
take sides because she likes me that's
like yesterday when we were talking
about listen you were like it's Jennifer
Teresa Danielle versus you Jackie and
Margaret it's like you didn't even
mention to Laura it's totally because
she is a neutral figure she Sweden but
she also is like she's the moral compass
she's a vicious Sweden you know no she's
not even she's not even Sweden she's not
on either side but in different
arguments she'll take a certain side
she'll right side what she thinks she's
like the moral compass of the show and
when I agree with Dolores I feel like
I'm on the right side right except the
only thing I time I didn't agree with
her was when she was saying that Melissa
should control her husband and but I
think that's because she'll always stare
into his eyes because like there it
would be like me always taking your side
like you did Emma we went on the show
together you were doing wrong things I
would be like when the camera rolling I
will tell you but then my plan would
never fight in public that's horrifying
no but not even that like I'm gonna have
your back like I'm never gonna like pile
on ya know oh my god no and that's what
I think the crux of the Melissa Teresa
beef is is that they both expect the
other to just automatically take their
sides because of family but they
disagree so wholeheartedly on almost
everything that it's impossible right
well the things that they disagree on
when it comes to other people if we were
on a show and we and other people were
fighting and you were taking one side
and I was taking the other I was I would
argue with you about what sides weren't
even or even just like talk but I would
be like why do you think that right but
that's time you could disagree and stuff
but if you were arguing with someone I
would never take the other person's side
no totally so the whole the whole
dynamic is very interesting that reunion
will be even more interesting given how
much things have changed
Melissa told us yesterday that I mean I
don't even think Melissa Birsa Teresa is
like a big it wasn't a thing this season
really they didn't butt heads that much
they buried the beef very civilly
but she said Teresa comes from II know
it felt like there was something brewing
at the beginning then when they went to
Bimini it was quelled by Joe Gorga and
then they got
distracted because of the drama with the
other ladies but that initial nugget of
what was brewing will now come out at
three unions I love Joe Gorga and I love
Joe be I forgot his lost now
Benigno I love the husband's so much and
the greatest line ever your husband's in
the pool yeah no Margaret Margaret Edie
Marty walking out goes she goes I'm out
your husband's in the pool she's like
who person well she goes me and my
husband no it's like that should
Margaret and Joe are like the least
gangster like he's so small like she's
so nice and the way they walked out of
that party it was like gangster season
being in my husband
it was just I wish from there she walked
out the door she had um no she got into
a few look fight so on the way you're
talking to Teresa about how thing else
acts like she should have just gave
Jennifer a hug and beelined so usually
my my life theory and the way I like to
live my life is if someone does
something chewin and they're in the
wrong but you react so outrageously it
doesn't matter what that person said so
it's like if you call me a [ __ ] you're
wrong but if I slap you in return I
automatically I'm out so it's like Marty
said some horrible things but Margaret
pushing me the pool was this
over-reactive kind of dramatic thing to
do and normally my mind would be like
well Margaret's now wrong she shouldn't
have thrown him in the pool but you know
what I don't think it wasn't even enough
it wasn't enough because there's
something about being pushed in the pool
that's not a big deal nobody no one gets
hurt if if Joe then punched him in the
face this would be a big brawl but
pushing him in the pool is just like get
the [ __ ] out of here like advice
seemingly harmless because babies really
just sue Claudia
alright Men's Wearhouse will go on you
know that was so good oh my god it was
such a you know Danielle was like
quaking about the watch like yeah and
he's like I can't sell it now it's just
such a good season I'm so interested
because Danielle really is at the crux
at the very end she is the reason for
this whole thing but she's not a
full-time housewife is she gonna be on
the reunion the whole time no no sweeter
and it's like he's broad we're gonna
bring her back because without her
there's not that much drama but it's
like when when all the drama is able to
be pinned on one person it's not even
that interesting cuz it's like we all
see so I actually had an interesting
thought while I was watching so I'm like
wow so Danielle really brought it this
season I think they're going
up graduate bring her to the next level
of being a full-time housewife and when
we saw her um she came on the breath
last year it was obvious that she was
working towards that and she was upset
she hadn't been asked yet but she
understood at the time that okay she
needed to work her way up at the fact
that she seasons in a row yeah but I
think they're really smart to keep her
as a only friend of housewife because
she's so motivated to make it to the
next level of actual full-time housewife
that she doesn't stop with the drama
like she's bringing it because she needs
to prove herself that if she actually
makes it she no longer needs to prove
you know yeah so I think it's a wise
decision just to keep her there yeah but
man I know wild what a season thank you
ladies on we cross the line it was uh
before we breakups yes Dukey a word from
our sponsors yes you guys because as you
know not only is it wedding season for
me tax season is coming up one of the
most important seasons and dreadful out
there dreadful but it can be less
dreadful and less you know complicated
with TurboTax live they have on-demand
CPAs and EAS that can answer your
questions and offer advice it's nice to
have a helping hand
especially when it's tax season and that
hand is attached to a license tax
professional with TurboTax lied you can
talk to real CPAs and EA's on demand who
can review your return with you before
you file and make sure you get your
maximum refund they keep they can even
check your work line by line so you can
be confident it's done right who knew
confidence and peace of mind could be
synonymous with taxes not me no I didn't
know the TurboTax live with CPAs and EAS
on demand see details at turbo tax calm
okay I what I made an error because when
I said that when I was done wedding
planning I was gonna get back to work
when I'm done wedding planning I'm going
to TurboTax live.com and then I'll get
back to work no I know I have to like
start printing out all my paperwork and
like the hardest part about doing my
taxes finding a printer is finding a
printer because there's someone who is
technically a freelancer but now also a
business owner and self-employed I have
very complicated taxes and I usually
need to print like all my bank and
credit card statements just like for
clarity just so I get myself organized
and I don't know where to print and
every time I need something printed here
it's like one page and I just I bought
everyone about it and like my my
printing is like like 200 pages you got
to go to Kinko's you know what the most
devastating part about getting fired
from the breath last year was
having a printer yeah yeah and not
having somewhere to ship all of our
packages like not having a corporate
card to put my UPS returns on anyways
what OCS Sookie it's getting kind of
boring I can't like I don't have much to
say I love Juliet whatever side she's on
I'm on the fight with clubbing Kelsey
was that was the most interesting part
and the fact that Polly's across from
classical pianist oh the poly and the
ponytail with the suit with the grandma
the grandma thing was so only the
grandma to move to the key yeah I mean
it was definitely really sad when he was
just saying like I have nobody like I
don't want to do it that's your grandma
it was really cute and sweet and
everyone has like a soft moment but I
mean I still think he's too many yeah
he's an evil loser and I just can't
stand it and like he started to say
something sweet he's like everyone wants
me to change me I'm not gonna change her
anyone but when my grandma's here I will
change for one night yeah Nick the piano
thing was so fun maybe I was like wow he
really respects his grandma for one
night no he respects his Maremma for one
reason I the money right I by the way I
didn't realize he had a $500,000 inherit
and said he completely blew through it
blew through but he has been warned
no but she just sends him money she like
beings for bankrolls his life I don't
know messed up someone I want to say I
don't know if she watches the s2 key but
someone who needs to send it to her I'm
sure she does but then she wouldn't be
bankrolling him totally and I need money
for I mean he just lives off of Alex no
but like drugs cause money oh your ankle
even when he's getting drinks with
Brandon drinks cost money yeah like you
know ponytails cost money yeah they do
that
you know biannual haircut is also
expensive yeah and then like when he's
like punching people and then he has to
get it's like ripping a neosporin and
band-aids the cost $10 yeah you know it
needs gas for his cars cost money
when he rolls up with the grandma that
was so funny the room as a boss I'm just
interested in the financials of it all
you know yeah because it's like like is
is Alex's dad rich because of the
grandma or is it different sides
I see rich on his own I think he's rich
Chinese don't like he's buying buildings
like he definitely was rich from the
grandma and in used his like moderate
amount of money his $500,000 inheritance
to do business to build into a business
like he owns buildings in siesta key
apparently he's like the
premiere lawyer you know how we have
like um Selena Barnes yes yes he's the
Cellino and Bart's of the key like he's
on all the commercial yeah like he's I
think the term is ambulance chaser so
the show is so great for him yeah and it
he seemed actually no it's a aside from
that conversation out without in the car
about how he could be like doing better
than Juliet and pulling all this tail he
seems like a good dad
really I don't know why do they have
like a really nice family and the only
time Alex has being a decent human is
when he's yeah his name is on point okay
so there is a troll who's been trolling
Alex's um Instagram claiming that outs
his little brother's actually his son
yeah and Alex replies to him so it's the
only reason I see it someone put it in
the toasters and I mean it's obviously
much colder I don't know they said
there's another brother who's Alex's son
he then he would have to be like three
or four ya know it makes no sense how
funny is I I don't know okay no but it
actually um when he's around his family
and the work that they do is like really
cute and when he was making a speech
Julie I was smiling so much it's just
like all these people have moments of
like being decent human beings and it's
like why don't you just be like that
year-round no it's like they have
moments of being decent human beings
Alex sees Juliet wow you look beautiful
like incredible then I always have the
hottest date I can't but I couldn't use
end the sentence halfway through that
fight between Chloe Kells he was real
why'd you gonna come to her place of
work though why did Kelsey admit she
kissed Jared when Chloe realized that
she had this information and then Kelsey
realized she just gave it to her yeah oh
my god her steamy brow line but pop I am
I am with Kelsey on this just a little
bit it's like it's not close business
it's not Chloe's business that's the
problem with all these reality shows
especially Vanna from pearls they all
get in each other's business and they're
fighting over the fact it's like no I
agree with you but get away it's my
business [ __ ] off right
Kelsey knows what she did was wrong and
she's gonna figure it out on her own but
she doesn't need Chloe blowing up her
spot making her look like a bigger liar
to her boyfriend like Chloe is becoming
an accountability coach when it's like
no one hired her no but Chloe's looking
so good she's using the most for the
show yes she is keeping the show moving
keeping everyone honest so that
everyone's fighting so like I understand
why she's doing what she's doing but
it's like on a friend level it's like
please like do that so
people would not me yeah it's annoying
I'd be annoyed too I hate people up in
my business okay so I'm sugar grab your
iPad
it's 1142 on okay Thursday morning
before we have to plug just everything
that we're doing this weekend
um because obviously you need to follow
me at Jackie O problems for premium
wedding content but you do not private
free running yes I am because like you
don't just get premium content doesn't
grow on trees and you don't just get to
stalk me and not follow me like what
doesn't follow me because it's also
premium content all the time you'll be
glad that you did you know give me the
stream for a second guys we're gonna
take some wedding questions for Jackie
because like this is the time okay and
I'm seeing when I look like Oh God so I
had a question for you what is your
gonna be your social media strategy on
the day do you have someone do I meet
like do I'm gonna be just taking
pictures non-stop do you have should you
hire someone like what you're gonna do
so my strategy is um I'll probably maybe
do a few stories like from my phone of
me getting ready but I really don't want
to see anyone to see what I look like
until I walk down the aisle like I want
my guests to have not have seen it
anywhere else yet so like no one is
allowed to like take pictures like post
pictures of me before we're getting
ready to because I really just want that
element of surprise like I've worked
really hard on like curating my look and
I want it to be like a moment and then
for mine I want to be able to post one
thing that night so hopefully I'll have
like a picture ready to go that I can
post and just like put my phone away I
mean it's gonna be a picture of just you
or you and Zach just me I think so too
like I'll have so much about him and
everyone has seen pictures of us like
it's about everyone wants to see the
dress and the look and like I'm gonna
give that to you guys
assuming I get a great picture and then
I think I might even leave my phone like
somewhere else because I'm not gonna be
on it at all
um and then everyone else will be
soaring so like you guys can follow or
maybe I'll keep my phone to like birch
or something and they can story the
party um but right now they're doing
such great stories at birch event design
just like getting ready for my wedding
they're getting me excited and like
nervous I'm realizing how close it is
yeah cuz they're like actually starting
like building right and then you can
follow all the scenes and then I think
after you know the day after through the
week after I'll probably post like over
20 images them from my wedding on my
Instagram feed and I just really am
hoping that when like that people I need
to like text all of the young people at
the party and be like these are the only
instrument or so you can use if you like
Aiden and Clara Don if you use Kelvin
like I will
never speak to you again like some of
the Instagram filters are so terrible I
just want to give like approved filters
okay like if you answer every question
that long like we're never gonna get the
questions that people ask and they're
really good okay
this from a leechers can you give any
details about your dress is a fitted
ballgown blingy lacy just give the
people a tiny bit of hope okay um is it
fitted ballgown tiny lacy I would say
it's some kind of a little bit of II it
has elements of you it's very it's like
kind of like princessy but it's but then
it's not and it's kind of ballgown me
but then it's not it's a modern ballgown
yeah it's vulgar
it's like modern traditional you know
medicinal hair upper hair down those are
you doing a first look yes what songs
will play during the ceremony
um I've worked too hard on curating that
setlist perfectly that I'm not giving it
away right now
what's your first dance song oh um
should I say like isn't that like so
private no no okay I'm not saying even
though I'm sure you guys can guess yeah
totally what is your something old
something new something borrowed
something blue a Jewish people to really
do that okay something old um let's see
what am I wearing something old maybe
I'll wear one thing old oh I'll
definitely like borrow jewelry like
we're having a mom yeah that wasn't
bought this year something borrowed from
something blue
Margot's eyes Margo's eyes and something
new everything else yes are you on a
month mini-moon yes we're bringing out
where I want to go just somewhere in the
u.s. I would even go somewhere like a
ski trip or somewhere cute like that um
but Zach like can't make up his mind I
would literally go anywhere will it be
alpha changes yes because like it's a
long night and I got to get down how
many I don't want to spoil it how many
um what color are you know we're lip kit
what kind we gonna join your lips you
know I'm really struggling with this
because I'm obviously I have my favorite
lip colors but like even in life is a
can I like don't even kiss a lot because
I get my lipstick on him so I think for
the actual ceremony I'm not I'm gonna
wear probably like what I'm wearing now
like something really like posing for
pictures I'll wear like a matte whatever
color I really want to wear but went for
the sour
like I want to be able to kiss him and
not then then he is wearing lipstick
after went for the pictures so I'm you
know what or even I'll wear it or just
icon II like a but it's still it feels
gross for the ceremony I'll probably
walk down and while we're up there I
will take it off yeah that's a good idea
just have like one of those those little
Neutrogena now they sell one packs oh
yeah that one will it be traditional
Jewish ceremony Orthodox conservative um
traditional closer to Orthodox but not
totally so like conservative but very
traditional I'm a traditional girl when
it comes to stuff like this I'm sorry
I'm are you extensions um I think I
might actually and actually really fun
tidbit about the extensions that I've
wearing that I'm wearing and I've been
wearing this would be a fun time to
announce is the extensions that I've
been wearing and the engines that I'm
wearing for my wedding are actually part
of an extension line that I'm coming out
with in collaboration with our PCL
they're gonna obviously have so many
great shades of red because like I
represent all the redheads around the
world but they're gonna have every color
and it's real hair it's amazing quality
I've been wearing them I've been loving
them and I'm gonna wear them on my
wedding day and then you'll be able to
buy them and you know what you should do
then your your collab should become your
own company where it's a non-profit
serving justice for redheads like you'll
get the emoji you'll get it take the
problem is though that my redheads are
such a minority it's like no one serves
them because like there aren't enough to
support a business this is the final
question because we are gonna do out
wedding patreon Q&A right after this so
if you're want to hear more about the
wedding feel free to join the patreon
but this question is too important from
Melissa Fuentes
can you fortnight in your dress and have
you tried and what kind of shoes are you
wearing because it's a very
labor-intensive move Melissa I'm so glad
you asked this question
I can fortnight in my dress yes I tried
when I was at the wedding salon I have a
video on my phone that I meant to send
you guys I mean they're hemming my dress
and I'm like I can do it I can do it so
yes and shoes are gonna be painful all
night um but I'm hoping that I'm so
exciting I have so much adrenaline that
I actually forget I'm not like changing
to like sneakers underneath no we can
see um maybe eventually but you know I'm
one of those people at other weddings
it's like some people when the
flip-flops come out they're the first
ones on I will wear my shoes until my
feet are broken I'm just like that kind
of like old school woman where it's like
a woman should be wearing heels until
she can but the way that I get that
that rule wasn't invented for the people
who dance like I do yeah so I really
struggle with it um and um if my feet
break I'll take my shoes off but I'm
gonna try I'm wear them as long as
possible because that's who I am as a
person know what you should do you
should make a spa appointment the next
day because you're gonna want your feet
rubbed yes that's a great idea yeah
maybe like an in-room azile
when I went to UM Mexico I went to the
spa and me and Ben got massages but I
spray tan so I was like being lame and I
was like can you just do it was an hour
so I'm like in you 30 minutes on my
scalp in 30 minutes on my feet it was
the best massage I ever had I'm never
doing a full-body massage again I hate
they rub my legs it's so weird and they
my back for so long it starts to hurt oh
I always tell them just get my legs
because I have such tender legs you
bruise easily like I'm you know it's
like I like you can't even touch me here
let alone rub yeah no I don't like it so
now scalp neck and feet the feet I was
snoring it was amazing it was just like
the ocean breeze and I was like wow and
the sound of my snoring kept waking me
up you know you know but you sounded
like a sound machine with your snoring
yeah we've been seeming with the sound
machine so actually really nice oh my
god are you for real yeah oh my god me
too
Ben has one on his phone a Zak has one
that he connects to his phone so he can
like turn it on and off when he's in the
other room so I know and like I go to
bed and he's doing something he doesn't
want me to hear he'll turn the sound
machine on like you're making a snack
right yeah like popcorn are watching
something loud he'll turn it out or when
he wants me to go to sleep right well
what sound do you do white noise me do
oh my god that's so weird Ben to start
it together sometimes you like Ben just
started cuz Ben loves the air
conditioning because it makes a loud
sound but sometimes it gets so [ __ ]
cold you can't turn it off so now he has
a mock air conditioning white noise app
yep and I do that get exactly where at
and so when bed was gone I never sleep
in my apartment alone because I'm
usually the one traveling but when Ben
was traveling and I was home I was so
afraid obviously and my windows make
this weird sound when the wind is really
bad and it wakes me up a mill the night
it's like oh great there's a robber so
the white noise drown out the sound of
the wind and they're like shaky Windows
has Theo to see you like it I actually
don't think so it's so sad also I'm so
excited for dr. Theodore for chairman to
come to my wedding it's a great honor
he's gonna join some photos yeah we
should we need to make sure to have lint
brush is like everywhere because he shed
so much [ __ ] yeah and you guys are gonna
add something great family photos and
excited I know did I tell you this or do
we sit on the show that I'm retaking my
wedding photos and we you told
we didn't say it on the show and then
I'm gonna I was talking about with a
couple people yesterday because I wanted
to know if was like a dumb thing to do
or like an extra thing to do but I'm
doing it do it I'm reaching even if it's
down and etcher
I'm taking my wedding photos I was still
fat and ugly and I hate those pictures
and I never use them because they're so
ugly pairs should great getting your
dress too while you're at it I think I'm
going to like a cheap one or a nice one
no it's like we're like there should be
dress rentals there is actually okay I'm
gonna do it early can you make wedding
dresses I can you want to let me borrow
one him yet
are you guys ready what would you do if
I showed up to your wedding a wedding
dress I would love you still that I go
to the sisters of the bride if they're
not married wear wedding dresses cuz
it's like you're next
um oh you know what you should do that's
weird you know you should do my friend
on I did I thought it was so sweet
you're not under the coping in a lot of
our diamonds so she took off all of her
jewellery from the pictures and she put
it in little pouches and she gave it to
all the single bridesmaids and it's like
a good luck thing so like you should
give you a ring tomorrow
just let her wear it down the aisle how
cute okay I will Mitchell steal it total
and I have something exciting to say
which is that shot Maureen host calm is
live right now shut morning joe calm
let's wait until we get our first order
then let's go yeah even read her address
okay know where he ya know any first
version to place an order
get the shoutout no first person to
place an order gets a free sticker
okay what about yeah actually we could
use five people will tell Zoe the orders
okay to throw sticker in okay head to
shop morning choice calm we have new pop
sockets new notebooks new shirts
sweatshirts we have clothes for babies
we have everything so if you go to shop
morning toast calm right now you're one
of the first five people to place an
order we will make sure you website
that's I've no password no password shop
morning toast go and dot actually I want
a free sticker I want to be the first
one to place an order
yes shame what are gonna get I'm
definitely get the race card shirt I'm
getting another sorority sweatshirt I
don't have a child but um
we should make dog clothes next time but
dogs are all different sizes that's
really hard at least babies all start
the same so I do need a shirt that said
Theo's mom would people wear it or it's
like your if your dogs not named Theia
or what if we made a shirt that said
Anthony chest cuz a lot of people are
ants you let us know also a lot of the
stuff that we created is because people
requested like I think someone requested
a bumper sticker so you guys let us know
like do out mark drinkware I
that's so basic I don't know what school
and March what we're doing is what
school yeah I think next drop we're
gonna do some like makeup cases some
sleeping masks some more like glamorous
stuff I said are you exciting yeah this
is just more ste NEMA dives merch and
more like fashionista I love the old
morning toast English I feel like we're
at Taylor Swift wonder where Pablo we're
probably the life of pop isn't that
weird they both have the same sort of
merge it wasn't just them two it was
like the world right did we get any
orders yet everyone said that's their
ordering okay it takes a while to put in
your credit card information I guess oh
wow yeah we already yeah we know sorry
it was it was updating it okay love oh
[ __ ] each of them so we know hold on
hold on
orders we're gonna say your name see you
all you win the free sticker okay the
first five were Chelsea lola kono Erica
Lally Bertie sorry
oh my god those are from the old stuff
sorry sorry sorry guys start over start
over
ash Alicia Stuart kami beverage
Stephanie Kristin Alexander Reinhardt
Hanna Barger Parker beau and I'm gonna
give you a shout out as number six
because I recognize you enjoy your nose
to go our parker bone we hope you guys
liked the march to make sure to tag us
in your pictures it's all pre-order you
get 24 hours till tomorrow
unlimited stock order as much as you
want nothing is gonna sell out it'll
come in two weeks
let us know tag us hashtag merch and
that's it
Wow cloud borders thanks guys you love
you next time I see you I'll be a
married woman baby Sadie mommy why do I
always do that because you know it in my
head it goes follow me out girls no job
and now I always say I jackieo problems
to subdue dude dude dude didn't know I
mean so plug your thirst and I'll sing
okay welcome fellow G add Jackie O
promises from premium content all
weekend I am hat like the wedding
weekend I'll be having a lot of bridal
looks before the actual wedding a bridal
looks but you know just food ride cry if
you want to Kauai means patreon.com
slash a morning toast I tell the whole
story of how I really got into being you
know the quiet girl that I am
at crook jackieo problems and pub with
no job at Claude with no job at girl
with no job at Morrigan tree at Alinea
are a boy with no job at then soccer and
then you can follow some of my wonderful
vendors who will probably need people
significant as well man's mean baskets
advert to that design at my keeper so my
wedding planner it's just gonna be a
great fun-filled weekend also I wanted
to end it on a note about you so you
gonna have to say something else but
because I wants to say something about
myself I got I went shopping yesterday I
think we're about to find out about me I
went shopping yesterday because there's
like pre-wedding festivities Shabbat all
that stuff and I bought a dress and I
just think everyone needs to know is a
size small I think that's also a great
note Anna because small season smoking
small life I'm okay shot morning toast
calm much ba hey see you next Tuesday
you